bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got
michael here with me thank you so much
for doing this sir
thanks for having me brother absolutely
i want to start off
uh i saw a article and it described you
as a pizza mogul which we're going to
get to in a second
but uh any pizza vogel who's got this
specific phrase is on one of the walls
of the uh the locations of and pizza
it says where it all takes shape where
decisions are made where pioneers walk
and walls talk why is that on the wall
of uh one of your locations yeah that's
some that's some of our weirdness
shining through so for every shop that
we design
prior to getting into the actual like
physical space our architecture and
interiors we start off with
inspiration and so we kind of go through
the history books and find out like
what made that particular location
whether it was a piece of land whether
it was a building
like exist in the first place then we
write some like off-the-wall copy around
it and that kind of leads us through the
uh process of eventually getting the
architecture and design work itself but
every pizza shop is designed differently
so it's part of the fun
process of you know flexing you know
what creative muscle we have and making
sure that
we're not thinking about this as you
know just multi-unit that every single
thing that we build has purpose and has
intention
and that we're paying homage to what was
there before but also doing our best to
bring
something of value to that neighborhood
or community that's a little bit
different
and that hopefully can you last a fairly
long time
and so when you think about the way
you're approaching this
everything seems to be different uh in
literally kind of thinking of it from
first principle standpoint uh the pizza
industry is cutthroat many people are
trying to find the most efficiency
they're trying to figure out how they
can systematize things
uh how they can almost make it clinical
to some degree you seem to be doing the
exact opposite
why yeah i mean for two reasons i think
the first is that if you kind of go back
to the origin story right this was much
more about a greater purpose we always
talk about the and
and and pizza coming before the actual
pizza right that was about
promoting unity uniting the working
class et cetera et cetera around fair
wages living wages but
on the pizza front i've always felt like
if you're going to do something
right new and you're going to enter into
an industry that you have
no experience or track record of
building or innovating or doing anything
inside of that you need to really bring
a strong point of view and that point of
view you know has to be you know
cross-functional meaning
rethinking every aspect of what it means
to make and serve and sell pizza
ultimately and you know kind of going
through the exercise of well
it's you know at the time it was 2010
2011 as we were ideating but
you know what would a modern version of
this look like but then most importantly
where do you want this to be 10 20 years
down the road
and so even when you think about like a
ventless and electric cooking platform i
remember i got laughed out of the room
i was on the rooftop of a hotel and
sweet grain has a sweet life where they
used to have a sweet life festival right
every year which is kind of cool for
like you know a multi-unit salad
you know brand of course they were much
more lifestyle but i remember they
introduced me the three founders
introduced me to a reporter
that was you know a journalist working
at eater and her first question was what
oven are you using because this is a
time in a place where
it's the neonapolitan craze and so if
you didn't like source that brick from
that oven at the bottom of mount
vesuvius like how dare you make pizza
and i'm sitting here actually it's uh
you know hybrid like electric
you know conveyor belt uh oven right
that's um people haven't necessarily
seen before but it was very
functional and the reason that we did
that is we knew that we wanted to
operate non-traditional
uh spaces and be able to make pizza from
anywhere it's relatively plug and play
and so even something like that that's
sort of wildly unpopular but
incredibly functional like we doubled
down on that and it was a thing that we
had to work through which is do people
think you can actually make a decent
pizza off of a conveyor belt
and so we just kind of rethought every
aspect willing to fail
right and put it all on the line
including coming to new york and
operating the toughest pizza marketplace
in the world
where most fast food entrants never come
or multi-unit never exists here
because you get slaughtered really
quickly and if it worked great if it
didn't work we were cool with that
as well what was your background uh it
doesn't sound like you grew up in a
family full of pizza makers so
what did you do before this well i i am
half italian so my dad loves the fact
that the
story he loves the fact that i am in the
pizza business
um but before this two things i i moved
to new york at 22 i grew up in a small
country town it was actually a hamlet
one flashing light one bar 500 people
i actually went to the same building
from kindergarten through 12th grade
like literally the same there was one
building and rode the bus and it's
always funny because
when you're in kindergarten you ride the
front of the bus and when you're a
senior you're at the back of the bus and
every year you move like one seat back
and find and that's just like that's a
small town rural america so maybe i went
to new york at 22 started up an ad tech
company
um that was my first startup because you
know i got a job basically in a boiler
making 350 phone calls a day and
realized that that wasn't going to be it
i didn't have a resume or a network that
was going to get me
any type of a corporate job that was
interesting and so it's basically
start your own thing or you know remain
in sales doing that and so
i started my own thing very early on got
lucky time
sort of ad tech market right i was able
to exit in four short years to a private
equity group stayed on board to run that
as ceo
uh for three years went through two
acquisitions and a merger
and then you know when my three-year
contract was up you know needless to say
i was i was out the door i reported into
private equity was not
not my thing uh but then started up a an
ad agency you know with my best friend
and partner doug jacob who you know
we've been in business for a long time
together
um now he's doing some really
interesting things with anvest and in
the spac world
but uh you know it was it was a creative
itch that we wanted to scratch and see
you know how do we actually make cool
stuff for founders and for executives
make them fall deeper in love with the
very brands that they were running or
that they created
and had a hell of a run there we sold
our agency in 2017 to a large japanese
beauty conglomerate shiseido
and along the way it was always looking
for
basically looking to create a company
that was about something more meaningful
to me personally
right that took sort of you know how and
where i was raised and applying that to
having lived you know in new york and
really wanted to quote unquote change
the world so this notion of
can we create a company that's really
focused on uh
high quality jobs i think that's one
thing in america that's really hard to
come by right now
there's too few of high quality jobs and
high quality food under a socially
conscious umbrella and that was sort of
the big mission
i think that's extremely important that
we don't talk about this notion of what
does it mean
to be a responsible employer or even
entrepreneur around like what are you
doing and i think great job creation is
extremely important since we've shifted
from
a manufacturing country to one of food
service food service industry employs 10
of america's workforce today which is
crazy and those jobs on average went
from 26 27
an hour to now 10 11 an hour and that's
been one of the greatest shifts that's
not talked about in terms of like income
inequality
is just that there's been a structural
shift in terms of where the jobs are
being created
and food service jobs are not doing uh
as good of a job as they ultimately
should
right by paying higher wages and taking
care of the workforce as a
responsibility as the largest employer
to do that and the restaurant industry
is the second largest private employer
outside the federal government so we've
got to do better
and i think part of doing better is
building a company by example and
proving that
your hypothesis around paying people
more and
being able to produce type of profit
that has people excited right to invest
in the concept and that it can grow
leading by example and then taking that
and being an open book and trying to
shove it
you know down every single fast food
executive's throat around like what you
actually can do if you approach it with
a different set of eyes
how do you guys solve that problem
so it's it's tough i mean every single
day you know we're talking about you
know what does it mean to be
you know a good employer and provide
high quality jobs right
started with wages i think wage is the
easiest solve right because that's just
transactional that means that
tomorrow you make a little bit less
because you're paying more
but over time actually the opposite
happens we've seen massive margin
uh tailwinds right our profitability on
a per shot basis has increased year over
year since 2017
where most in the industry is going the
opposite direction because we see such
exceptional productivity
right with respect to labor and people
care deeply when they walk into the four
walls of a pizza shop right they treat
it like it's their own
mainly because they respect and trust
the company its leadership that
we actually have their back and every
time that we've been challenged
right we do step up on their behalf but
then that's the starting point right now
we've taken it as far as providing paid
time
off for activism right this summer we
give three full
uh days of paid time off for that so
people can you know get out there and
allow their kind of voice to be heard
so that they can meet other people that
are like-minded and get
around the causes that they ultimately
want to support like that's that's as
far as it's going and i think was much
further we could go as an employer but
you got to constantly be
finger on the pulse communicating with
your workforce
and thinking about you know what would
you want ultimately
and then listening to what they would
want in terms of that relationship and
you start treating the people as like
friends with shared interests versus the
employer employee thing
and it starts to work but look it's
taken
we're i mean we're coming on coming up
on a decade here right and it's taken
every hour of every single day of those
10 years
for us to get directionally correct
around what does it mean
and how can we be you know a better
employer across the board so it's like
you got to just constantly chop wood
every single day
and you'll get the breakthroughs in
terms of the progressive policies that
actually stick
right where eighty percent of the
workforce is using them and they talk
about that stuff is the reason why
they're working for the organization
you've raised uh over 100 million
dollars to this point from some
very very well-known investors i don't
know if you want to share who some of
them are or not
um but why are they interested in this
it's not every day that you see some of
these folks
uh investing in not only a
pizza and kind of fast uh casual if you
will
type experience but on on top of that uh
you've got this like
non-economic mission as well and so
what's driving that investment interest
yeah i think i i think they see the
vision in terms of you know what
something like this can be at scale
and when you think about like especially
in our industry go back
and look at like legacy fast food like
who wouldn't want to own
in-n-out's balance sheet right in now
burger right now
uh is is thriving but you know they were
the ogs of paying living wages
right that was one of the best jobs that
you could get in california
right they were paying up taking care of
their workforce i mean they have a
religious bend to them
right which is sort of where their
values originate from
and it's worked starbucks is the same
thing right progressive policies across
the board taking care of their workforce
the first to offer bean stock to every
single employee so it's like
when you go back and look at companies
that were built the right way
and if you have time to hold on to that
investment you believe that the person
is
authentic that has a differentiated
brand and product
and you believe it can change an
industry like that's a good place to
park capital but again we've targeted
family office money
right we've stayed away from traditional
private equity because the returns
um have to happen too soon right three
to five years
is too short a time period to invest in
a business like this because
you know we're in year 10 and we're just
getting started with it all kind of
coming together and that hyper growth
really come into fruition
because when you're building something
you know the right way it doesn't only
only so fast you can ultimately go so
when i think about uh the pitch right
kind of the
the uh story as to why you're doing this
and how it's playing out
uh i think some people get confused they
say oh this is a social impact thing
right this is uh this is not a
for-profit type endeavor
uh they couldn't be further from the
truth uh from what i understand
what metrics can you share with us just
in terms of how big the business is
um whatever you're you're kind of
comfortable sharing to really just prove
that hey look this isn't just about
the social impact there's a real
attractive business that's driving all
of this
yeah it's um yeah i guess you could call
a little bit more conscious capitalism
there's a lot out there you know
different versions of fill in the blank
capitalism
that that sort of describes this you
know i think it's
it is important to note that you know
for us to make an impact
we have to show proof that you know our
hypotheses are actually coming to
fruition and you can't go
to you know an advocacy group you can't
go
to mcdonald's ceo you know with numbers
that are upside down because anybody can
spend money and lose money it's a pretty
easy thing to do and we've seen it
in many tech companies not hard right to
take a bunch of money
and burn it so you you actually have to
be very disciplined with the economic
model that you're building
uh and for us you know we're coming up
on
um 25 for wall margins you know 50
cash on cash returns which basically
means that we're paying back
you know our pizza shops within two
years which is best in class 25
margins the last time that we saw that
was chipotle
right and shake shack kind of at the
peak i mean we're doing 20 margins north
20 margin intracovered right now
and so the business is very profitable
uh and you know i give a lot of that too
of course like the technology and the
operating system that we built but the
labor productivity and our family and
workforce coming together and showing up
we have 50 locations now and you know we
are opening
27 this year we actually opened 11
locations in tricovid which was really
cool
right agreed to pay you know play
offense really early on make big
investments in our people
get back to swinging hammers and opening
up pizza shops and uh you know we will
triple in size in the next three years
that's what we are capitalized for
and that's the direction that we're
ultimately going primarily on the
eastern seaboard so think from boston
all the way down through atlanta
and filling aggressively in those
markets to make sure that we're
clustering right the way dominoes that
we're saturating making it really easy
to get our pizza
and getting closer and closer and closer
to our customers
yeah it's absolutely amazing and i think
a lot of what's driving the the interest
and
and also the growth of the business it's
this very kind of innovative approach
that you're taking uh to various aspects
of the business
uh i kind of think of it as a first
principles uh thought process or a
systems thinking
um and those are playing out in a whole
bunch of different
uh kind of mechanisms i'm gonna throw a
couple of those out there and if you can
just
riff on where'd the idea come from how
did you implement it and how's it going
uh the first being the mobile kitchens
so maybe describe what is a mobile
kitchen and where'd that idea come from
yeah you think about it like a you know
a larger
food truck that looks a little bit more
like a hybrid food truck
semi um and the notion was
you know can we produce the same
quantity of pies that we do in a pizza
shop
in something on wheels where we're
taking less overall real estate exposure
and we can scale faster right because of
the mobility aspect of it and we can do
it infinitely
for far less capital right we're fully
outfitting a mobile kitchen
it's a 200 000 capital outlay right a
pizza shop
is a you know called between 650 and 750
000 cash outlet and so if you can do
more of them
faster with less risk and exposure and
get closer to your customers that could
be a really interesting thing
part of the challenge with it is you
know that was very innovative but now
intra-coveted as a lot of markets and
real estate are getting repriced
right it's actually easier for us to
just go build pizza shops we've kind of
pulled back a little bit on the mobility
pressed forward on the pizza shop you
know suburban expansion
which has been in our plan but we find
ways to use them
to basically extend now the pizza shops
themselves so i'll look at a pizza shop
and say it's doing
you know two million dollars of revenue
but also recognizing that
between a 10 minute and 15 minute drive
right there's half a million dollars of
revenue there
and yet i know that i really don't want
to be exceeding
a 10 minute drive time right because the
quality of the pizza starts to
deteriorate right once it's sitting
right outside of a hot box or you know
the further and further away it goes
from the oven itself
and so you can put you know a mobile
kitchen there
it doesn't have to necessarily be main
and main and all of a sudden now you're
serving
higher quality pies faster to that
customer base and you can extend the
radius further out from there so you've
picked up
incremental revenue and providing higher
quality revenue we talk about that a lot
because
i think one of the biggest challenges
that the food industry has is that
there's been a lot of low
quality revenue there's been a lot of
mediocre delivery
even from great branded restaurants that
now that kind of sizzle of what made
them special which was the four-wall
experience
they don't have the muscle and they
don't have like the the actual
off-premise
or delivery in the dna of the
organization
and so it's not playing to their
strengths and that's a real big
challenge like most restaurant brands
are e-commerce companies
and if you look at you know the
executives and you look at the resumes
of those executives like that's not what
you would hire if you're building an
e-commerce company
right it's about production it's about
logistics right it's about
uh customer acquisition like real
omnichannel customer acquisition like
things that we talk about
other industries but you'll never find
an intelligent conversation around like
true customer acquisition
right in the restaurant business because
it's very foreign to
many of the operators and entrepreneurs
and so that's one of the things that's
going to be
i think some of the biggest challenges
is that the structural shift it's a
different business if you don't have
that
skill center capability organization
it's going to be painful and people are
going to be more particular
like people are going to care is there
more options as restaurants reopen
they're going to want better quality
food and they're going to expect that
food that's supposed to be hot shows up
at your doorstep hot
if you can't deliver on that like
they're going to go elsewhere
it's fascinating to hear you think about
kind of that four wall experience
uh and the mobile experience as really
just kitchens
one is mobile one is not uh but it's
what is the proximity to geography
and drive distance and it almost feels
like you're talking about the mobile
and static uh experience in kitchen as
uh very comparable actually it's more so
just
one has a unique feature that i can move
and the other does it and so you can
kind of mix and match as you see fit to
serve the customer
and look whether you're domino's amazon
walmart
like it's about you know fulfillment and
the fulfillment centers you ultimately
want to get closer to your customers so
you can execute
right if we're talking about like bigger
box like they want you know sub one hour
execution of on-demand ordering to get
whatever you want
in food like the intra-covered
experience of this kind of like
30 to 45 minutes candidly it's [ __ ]
like
that's a terrible amount of time to wait
when you can get probably something from
amazon
in the same amount of time frame so like
we need to get in food down to these
you know sub 15 and i think 10 minute
you know times from the time that you
press
you know that on your phone something
showing up at your doorstep and that's
going to be i think one of the biggest
hurdles is that
you know the competition expectation for
what on demand ordering
actually looks like and the fulfillment
of that like the bar is raising and the
bars not necessarily being raised by
you know food service or even the market
places like the ubers and the doordash
love them
right but they've got a lot of kinks to
work through in terms of being a hell of
a lot faster
and on top of that like actually setting
up
like fleets and courier networks that
are are capable of and have the
resources to handle hot food
and part of the reason why food shows up
in all different types of
forms is that you could have you know
pizza
right being delivered and there's a cold
item that's going to someone else right
after your visit and your pizza's been
sitting on top of something cold it's
just sucking the life out of it
like that's a real issue and something
that needs to be addressed but yes i
agree with you
it's all about production it's all about
logistics all about fulfillment centers
and how do we get closer to our
customers
to meet that on-demand off-premise ask
right that needs to get faster and needs
to get better and it needs to happen
really quickly
or else you're going to lose i think a
lot of what you potentially gained in
trokovic from
you know a new digital customer because
they have a ton of optionality
another one of the innovations that you
guys have driven is this pizza cube
what is that it's the same thing you'll
think just like a kiosk
so it's just a a lighter capex way to
build a pizza shop um that in theory
you know can uh be stood up right
uh in you know call it half of the
actual like construction time
and can be broken down and transported
so
you know no different than a shipping
container it's just you know small box
production
uh with the key that we can make and
produce pies in 300 square feet
no different than we make in producing 1
500 or 2 000 square feet and that just
brings costs down and allows for that
incremental scale
and i think that's an incredibly
important thing plus again
when we talk about this notion of
getting closer to the customer you can't
be spending the same amount of cash
every single time i mean if my uh
limiting factor is that i need to hit
the cash on cash returns for a 750 000
square foot pizza box
you know i'm not going to be able to do
that right across the city
and make it work i'll be missing big
pockets where
you know there's revenue there but maybe
not the revenue that pays back the 750
000 investment but there's revenue that
will pay back a 400 000
investment or 200 000 investment and so
when you look at like cash and cash
returns we don't need to do
two million dollars per box if i spend
half the amount of money
i can do a million dollars in a
particular pizza shop and that will work
just as well
right because you're generating the same
cash and cash returns
yeah when you think about this uh
people might hear oh he wants to get the
pizza to them in 10 minutes
uh how do i keep my margins how do i do
this in 300 square feet rather than 1500
square feet
what they're not hearing is uh i want to
make the best pizza in the world
uh but i think that again a
misconception may be that you
are willing to kind of give up some of
the quality of the product itself in
pursuit of this innovation
or these efficiencies talk a little bit
how you think about balancing
uh the innovation and the technology and
some of the more
um kind of you know forward thinking
stuff with just the
key being the pizza's got to taste good
yeah i mean that's
we don't talk about that often mainly
because
to some extent it's a commodity and
what people like in terms of what their
best pizza is often very subjective
and oftentimes has to do with where they
grew up and the pizza they consumed as a
child because you have this
psychological connection to this product
that you loved
and that's your version of what pizza
should taste like
you know people that live in new york
for extended period of time it's hard
for them to eat pizza elsewhere because
that's their version of really good
pizza i don't
disagree i think new york makes some of
the best pizza in the world right i'm
biased to that
but i think the key is for us is that
you know part of the
downside to fast food is that it's
incredibly chemical laden
right the manufacturing the production
process
of big pizza and fast food at scale
right
is is not actually what you want to put
in your body if you look at a more
recent video that was posted like 54
ingredients go into making a big mac
right you know well it's like the first
one you can literally like
it can like corrode and erode metal so
it's just like
it's so so part of getting closer to
customers is that
clean food right which our supply chain
is incredibly clean it gets colder
faster right it doesn't actually have
the stain power that unclean and
chemical-laden food ultimately does
and so that's a big part of it yes i
know the demand is going to be there
because people are going to want us to
get to the doorstep faster
but for us it's actually solving for the
high quality
food because the stuff that we source
and the stuff that we put on the pizza
isn't going to taste as good 30 minutes
versus right out of the oven
right because we're not doing the big
pizza hacks in terms of the things that
they do to keep the food
hotter and and to make the food
ultimately travel
longer because we actually care deeply
about what people are consuming and what
they're putting into their bodies we
won't compromise on that we spend a lot
of time
on the r d specifically around that
which is
how do you make clean healthier right
because it's still pizza
ingredients travel and still taste
delicious and the honest
answer is get there faster and reduce
the delivery times because it's a really
hard thing to do it's a very slippery
slope once you start compromising
which we won't we never have right the
actual quality of the ingredients
because you can make things that taste
really good
that are really bad for you and we're
trying to avoid that yes we're in the
pizza category but
we still think that you know 10 20 years
from now people are going to
be consuming healthier versions of it
it's just pizza as an
industry is so far behind it's
fascinating like the last to get on the
vegan train there's
one large national pizza chain that now
is buying product from beyond
and i was talking to the executive
chairman the other day and they're just
not calling in me while i'm banging down
the door being like where's my vegan
pepperoni
that's the number one product innovation
and request that we don't have right now
it's just because it's a very dated and
tired industry as it relates to quality
of food
when you have someone like white castle
right white castle has
a vegan product and they had it years
before anyone in pizza which is just
baffling so
we're trying to stay you know finger on
the pulse of you know globalization of
making indulgent food taste really good
and and making sure that you know the
quality of the supply chain
is you know as a 10 out of 10 and is as
clean as humanly possible because we
don't want to make you feel like you
have to take a nap
and that's what you'll feel if you have
lower quality
ingredients and pizza it's like people
go to italy they're blown away at how
they eat
and consume and yet feel great right
like
it's uh you know there's a way to make
it happen where you're not clogging up
you know your gut and and wanting to
take a nap every day
a lot of the innovations we've talked
about are what i'll consider technology
innovations or platform innovations
uh another thing is just the way that
you interact with your employees uh
you've given your cell phone number as
far as i understand
to everyone literally from the cashier
to the
store manager to people in the back
office uh
vendors the whole nine yards why are you
doing that and then what's been
uh kind of the impact of it do people
call you all day long and text you
and they're complaining or cheering you
on or what
what's happened since you've done that
it's been it's been
yes it's a bit of an experiment but for
me it's you know part of the reason why
i got into the business in the first
place
but you can't say you know we're focused
on high quality jobs high quality pizza
under a socially conscious umbrella and
then not be focused on those three
things and so for
me providing high quality jobs
means that i need to be very close to
the workforce
i need to be there and accessible day in
and day out
hour and an hour out or as a leader so
that i'm getting all of the data
right that i can around what's working
what's not working how can be a better
employer i think on top of that though
it's also the part of the business that
i love the most
right that's where a lot of my
inspiration comes from which is yeah
sure you have to deal with from time to
time
you know some of the negativity if
someone had you know has an employee a
bad experience or was frustrated
you know or their manager or their boss
you know did x y and z
helpful data points but then oftentimes
it's you know
them thanking or reaching out with
product innovation
with inspiration with hey i came across
this what do you think
and that's the type of stuff that makes
me feel more connected and that
connection i think is is deeply human
deeply personal
uh gives me more empathy right as a
leader
and and i think like helps me get
through some of the toughest
days when you're balancing you know a
very dynamic business in the middle of a
pandemic right it's the
people side of the business the most
human side of it that is the most
rewarding
and the text message platform like we
have that for all communication now so
you can't call and and pizza as a
customer
you can't email us it's all done via
text and you know our sla in terms of
getting back to people now is right
around 90 seconds and we do it with
actual
human beings not chat bots or automation
you get a live person on the other end
of that text
which i think is really cool and we use
that for our workforce as well so
everyone has my number they also have um
you know the number right that goes to
the same group of people so
employees can talk to me or they can
talk to any of our family members that
are working you know the text line
day in and day out and get access to
anyone i make sure that's an important
thing
every executive needs to be wildly
accessible like i am incessant on if you
write me an email
you will get an email back right if you
track me down on linkedin as annoying as
that platform can be
right with all the pre-canned messages
that you get like i respond to
every single one and i try to make sure
every single person that comes to work
for aunt pizza does the same because i
know it was like in sales
right reaching out to people i know what
it was like on the other end and i just
try to make
you know whether it's employee or
customer accommodation and be there be
available and be very quick with rapid
response
yeah it's fantastic uh we've talked
about
the mobile kitchens the pizza cube uh
this
uh kind of cell phone uh experiment uh
which all seemed to be
positive outcomes for innovative
thinking and first principles thinking
what are some examples of things that
you guys have tried in the past that
haven't worked
and then at what point did you realize
hey this isn't working and we should
kind of give up on it and move on to
other ideas that we have
well i think that the mobility i think
was a big one
right it didn't get the scale that we
initially intended largely because
as i mentioned you know sort of the
pandemic shifted right the focus but the
other side of it was actually too
early on from an innovation standpoint
jurisdictions
right like cities and counties they
didn't know what to do with this thing
they didn't know what to classify it as
and so it was really hard to get permits
i mean you have a lot of experience
right in that meaning like they just
didn't know like what do i do with this
thing it's not a food truck it's too
long to be a food truck it's not
and so it like we literally are in like
multiple counties like waiting on
permits now
all over right pennsylvania maryland
virginia et cetera and there are still
to this day
like they're stuck on desks because
people don't know what to do with them
so like
there's issues there where sometimes
being a little bit further ahead on
certain things
and there's a solve for that it's just
wildly expensive we don't have the
capital to go really solve for that
right to go beat down the doors the
right way and so like that would be a
good example of like
probably too early and there's probably
another
way to go do it which we've solved for
in you know smaller footprint
and now kind of our version of ghost
kitchens which i think a lot of that
business is
i don't use the word garbage but i think
it's it's pretty low brow like there's a
lot there that
doesn't work for me that i think is a
lot of hype and not a lot of sizzle or
substance
and it's like domino's has been doing
basically a ghost kitchen
for decades now right when you find a
dominoes it's like you took
two wrong left-hand turns right in a
neighborhood that you were unfamiliar
with and there's a dominoes because the
real estate costs nothing
they're hoping that people don't
actually drive up to it they're just
using it as a delivery hub
so they've been around for a long time
um but but that's
that's a good example but i would also
say like we made a lot of
uh software investments like we built
our own software stack and operating
system that
you know was very early on and we were
kind of building alongside some of the
third-party software systems that were
out there
we didn't want to cobble together we
wanted to be able to own it because we
thought it was going to be a
differentiator and it is
but it's expensive if i go back say
maybe we could have gotten away
earlier in the life cycle of just using
what was out there
focusing elsewhere and not spending the
type of capital but then a pandemic hits
and you have a platform and it works and
you go from two-thirds
in shop to 100 digital overnight and all
of a sudden you know shareholders are
are cheering you on because you made
those big investments and it worked and
that's what kept your doors open
so it's like those little things where
it's like you asked me two years ago
yeah we probably spent too much on tech
too early on mobility
and we work a hell of a lot harder than
we should like that's i would say like
working for and pizza is a very
difficult job right you're going to be
asked to fly at 50 000 feet
and be in the weeds right you're going
to be asked to be innovating while
you're also
operating and that could put a lot of
stress and strain on the business like
the things that we do are unproven
often you don't know if they're going to
work and you're working twice as hard
for in many cases the same results
because you don't know what that
breakthrough thing is ultimately going
to be so we could make it
a heck of a lot easier on ourselves by
not doing a lot of this stuff and
probably would have seen
a similar amount of success because we
didn't need to do 30 things we just
needed to do three things
but that's just not you know my
personality your perspective on like how
i think we need to win which is change
everything to the point you made earlier
which is a little it is a little crazy
it's a little bat [ __ ] crazy but
it's the type of company i feel like if
we can get to the other side and we're
starting to get there that you know
there'll be a good
you know multi-decade run based on the
engine and the way it was built
right where there's going to be a lot of
relevance 10 20 30 years from now
because of how hard we worked at trying
to get it right and get every aspect of
it right
and not just differentiation or
innovation for innovation's sake because
that's purposeless but
where there's actually a reason for
everything to be different
and it all makes sense right in a world
that is now
shifting dramatically from analog to
digital and
every restaurant brand now needs to have
a lot of the stuff that we built
and needs to have this type of thinking
because who wants to pay for 3000 square
feet when you can do it
in 500 square feet and far fewer people
actually want to sit
right inside of your shake shack or your
sweet grain or your and pizza
it's very true one of the ideas i'm
really fascinated with
uh lately is this idea of entrepreneurs
as investors and what i mean by that is
uh you've got capital uh both financial
and intellectual capital
uh that you manage and you have to
choose when and where
to make those investments um and measure
what is the return on the investment
how do you think about that uh as
founder and ceo of a business
and uh are there things that you've
learned over the years that other
founders or ceos can learn from uh in
terms of
those investments of both the
intellectual and financial capital
yeah i mean it's we we have a bit of a
luxury
in that the cash on cash return metric
in our business is
is so uh obvious
right and so straightforward so if we're
going to make
right a non-pizza shop investment and
something potentially non-traditional
whether that's investing
in an interesting product that we're
going to put
right on the pizza and we're going to
kind of blow it out
a good example i personally invested in
mike's hot honey and and we pushed that
brand very hard it's done incredibly
well i mean kudos to the team there
uh mike and matt um and and we share
investors and that business is literally
like a 10 out of 10 right now but a lot
of it just comes back to we're actually
looking at making some non-traditional
investments right now it comes back to
you know can we beat the cash on cash
returns
that we typically would invest in
building on a pizza shop
and then that's sort of the guiding
light that we look through all of this
and so there is some
um there's real math that goes into it
but we've been
we've been very i think conservative
around that because the end of the
day you know the fastest path for us to
get scale to be able to
really do that is by opening up more
pizza shops and driving this
you know trucks straight down the middle
of the field and so just making sure
that we're not getting overly distracted
but look like there's days i would love
to park our balance sheet into bitcoin
right and be one of those guys right
because of course then you're heroic and
you don't need to raise capital because
you just raised all the capital that you
needed
like going from ten thousand up to sixty
thousand like that's
there are days you wanna do that stuff
but that's you know that's a bit risky
and you know the investors and
shareholders didn't sign up for that
type of thinking so we'll be crazy but
we won't be as crazy there
it feels like it's easy to sell people
on making an investment in
mike's hot honey uh or another pizza
shop the whole bitcoin conversation is a
whole different ball game absolutely but
but i can appreciate that you've thought
about it that is uh
that might be the most important part uh
before i get into the rapid fire
questions to uh to wrap us up here
what's your favorite memory over the
last decade of building and pizza
my favorite memory two of them one was
when the mayor of washington dc
signed legislation to increase the wage
in dc to 15 an hour and she did it
outside of an ant pizza and we were a
big part of it since we've been
championing that movement for a long
time
and to do it you know there with you
know a whole bunch of ant pizza family
members like that was a really special
moment
and then introducing the first raise the
wage act on capitol hill with senator
sanders
senator pelosi and senator schumer we've
gone through obviously as you know
multiple iterations and
i'm super bummed that you know minimum
wage got pulled out of you know the most
recent legislation and really hoping
that we can do everything in our power
to
wind that back up but that was a pretty
proud moment because the only reason i
was there
is because you know we uh built that
into
the business model and the business
model worked and so we're a part of a
lot of
you know councils around how you can
make this work
right and you can profit from it and so
you know
with a vision to a piece of legislation
that of course ultimately went nowhere
but just to know that
you know anyone can kind of dream big as
it relates to
wanting to actually change the way
people think and change federal policy
and be there
and to be a part of it because of a cool
pizza business that you built
um you know i'll never forget that and
you know we're going to keep fighting
that good fight and hopefully we'll get
that minimum wage to where it needs to
be
but i look back at that and i say damn
it wasn't for the amazing people like
and
and to be able to have this platform to
do stuff like that i can't imagine doing
anything else in this world like for a
job
right because as an entrepreneur you're
building a company to go work for like i
think it's fantastic
i love that answer that's a fantastic
answer uh i got three questions for
rapid fire and you get to test me one to
finish this up
uh first is what is the most important
book you've ever read
it's tough because i there are so many
like i never had a traditional mentor
growing up because i grew up in such a
small rural
town and so it was the books that got me
through i i want to say
probably the first one that
made me think about the employer
employee relationship a little bit
different was let my people go surfing
and it's it's the it's the founder of
patagonia he's an odd bird
uh but it's it's uh it was just really
interesting to kind of get the
perspective you know he's a man that
built
product around a real need and
you know had a really different approach
to you know what it meant to be an
employer and that really helped open my
eyes to it
what was the takeaway you had from the
book like was there one thing that you
were like
just hey it's different or was it
something more specific
the takeaway was you can march to the
beat of your own drummer
and you can build a company successfully
that gets better
you know over decades by you know having
a different type of a culture
and you know setting up policies to be
progressive and to support
ultimately what the workforce is all
about some i mean some of the best
companies culturally are those where
you know the people working there are
are actually living
ambassadors of the brand you think about
the patagonia as the reis like there's
not a day that you don't walk into
or at least pre-covered you know those
retail stores those people weak
of that like they are working there to
get the gear at a discount
and they have their next three trips
planned right where they're going to be
out there
like literally living the brand whether
it's snowboarding or skiing or
you know mountain climbing like that's
it and like that
that but that can be applied to every
industry
right it just it's not just about like
um
you know those types of come you you we
applied it to pizza and that's like what
paid time off for activism is to us
right it doesn't have to be about the
trip that you planned it can simply be
about i want to go work for a company
that supports my activism
and that gives me paid time to go do it
why not and we're washington dc
headquartered
like what a great idea for a washington
dc company to lean into activism
that's one of these cities right across
america one of the most popular cities
for
movements right and for marches and so i
think it's a great benefit so that to us
is like
you know our version of that where it's
not like 50
discount because you can get all the
free pizza you want you kept working on
pizza but it's this notion of
expressing who you are and your beliefs
out there in the public and letting the
backing of the company and the resources
that we have to help pro
you know promote that and support you
you know whatever that may be
yeah that's a a great answer second
question is
about your sleep schedule comes from our
friends over at eight
sleep they've got this thermo-regulated
bed that i sleep on which
uh today i sleep super cold my wife
sleeps super hot
and i sleep like a little baby but i
used to only sleep five or six
hours what's your sleep schedule been
over the years are you uh
gotta get your eight hours you don't
sleep a lot and how has that changed
yeah so i so what is the product again
i'm actually i may need to get this it's
a thermoregulated bed so basically
uh you can get a mattress or like a
cover to go over an existing mattress
and then you essentially can uh at four
different points through the night
the temperature can be set so you can
start you know kind of neutral
and then get colder and colder through
the night and then right before you wake
up it'll kind of warm up
uh but basically the the thought
processes especially for men i think
uh sleeping in a colder environment
actually gets you more
rem gets you kind of that deeper sleep
you wake up feeling more refreshed uh
and so the uh the founders over there
um literally uh convinced me to become
like this convert of the sleep religion
i gotta get my eight hours now
and i started sleeping on this thing and
i called him up and i was like dude i
gotta invest in this like this is
amazing
and so i'm a full-on convert now for
sure
and what was the brand uh eight sleep
oh yeah okay i've heard all right i
actually i've been i'm gonna do this
right now
i'm gonna buy one no it's i'm telling
you
everyone that has this has been telling
me about it
and it's exactly that like i used to
sleep you know growing up in buffalo
with the windows open the dead of you
know
winter and like i crave that i need it
to be freezing my my sleep is not great
like if i want to get six hours of sleep
i have to be in bed for eight and a half
hours
like i'm constantly moving i wear an
aura ring that tracks it that like just
gives me anxiety now in the morning
when i'm opening the app and it's going
to tell me i didn't do what my body
ultimately wanted to do right it's like
that i've got like this mental torture
but
sleep has always been difficult for me
and the main reason for it is that i
don't sleep well and when my head hits
the pillow
it's just this onslaught of like
ideation
that like comes out of left field and
nowhere actually my best ideas are when
i'm like half awake
when just it all comes together and i
have to get up and write it down but
it's
sleep has never been my friend but i'm
gonna i'm gonna get this eight so i'm
gonna get the um
the mattress cover pod and
yeah the pod yeah i'm gonna get the pod
i listen i've told a lot of people about
i've never had someone buy it on the
spot
so you uh i'm all in eight sleep let's
go
i love it uh third question for you is a
little bit more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
[Laughter]
this one gets you in trouble i i i would
like to believe
in aliens and i like the idea
right that there's life outside because
i think it creates
a lot more um empathy
and it's humbling right anytime you can
remove yourself and look at something
bigger like you're a microcosm of the
universe i think that's a really good
thing
like look like all we can do is be the
best version of ourselves like things
are going to happen so i love the idea
of aliens because
it makes me feel less relevant it makes
you know
our species feel less relevant than
there are times over the past 12 months
where i think that's been a good thing
but i think it just reminds us that you
know we are a small part of something
much bigger than ourselves and it's a
really healthy reminder of it so
i'm on the pro alien side uh i'm right
there with you i think that
probabilistically uh they're real
they're somewhere i don't know if
they're green men but uh but there's
something out there
so we'll see you get to ask me one
question and finish up what you got for
me
all right so what would you do i guess
the question would be pizza nfts
right you're me right now do you do
anything with it or do you let it go
i think that there's uh there's a
balance right and
i think of it less is like pizza and i
think of it more as community and really
what you're trying to do
is you either want to create really
really unique experiences
or you want to essentially look at it
almost like merchandise right so i say
what's the difference between taking
let's say an image
uh putting it on a t-shirt and selling
it putting that same image on a poster
or putting that same image in a digital
uh kind of environment and so uh i think
that you've got to almost think of it
from like the value to the audience
right and one of the mistakes i see uh
brands or individuals make is they're
just like oh i can make money
and you know i think that the way that
you guys have built the and pizza brand
is like that's as far
away from kind of the values and the
approach you've taken
so you want to just really be really
really thoughtful about like okay what
is this and so
uh one of the things that could be
really interesting for you guys
specifically is
imagine if you basically tied the uh
nfts into some sort of uh experience
right so if you said hey we're gonna you
know auction off five or ten of these
uh and whoever buys them we're gonna fly
them in for a private dinner with you
and the team
and they get to meet the investors or
see kind of behind the scenes or shadow
you know for a day or
you'd have to kind of you know think
through like what is actually like a
really really valuable experience
but that's something where all of a
sudden is there really a difference
between like
selling tickets on eventbrite versus the
nfts no
not necessarily but i do think that
there's a ton of people specifically
that have
cryptocurrencies right they want to buy
other digital goods and so you're just
showing up and kind of selling something
in a new environment rather than the old
environment
but you can get really creative right so
i think like that stuff's super
interesting
the other thing that i haven't seen
people do yet is everyone so far has
been thinking about like how do i sell
the nft
but what happens if all of a sudden you
were to say hey you know what we're
gonna do whoever is the number one
customer at each one of our locations
we're gonna give it to you so rather
than give you like a trophy
what if we give you this like digital
good right and maybe there's some cool
thing that you can do kind of with that
so
i think that people are kind of just
scratching the surface with kind of
what's possible they're starting to
understand the technology
uh and kind of all the different
iterations five years from now i think
you and i are gonna be blown away by
what people figure out and kind of how
creative they are
but i think that's what makes it fun
right now right it's like let's see what
people do
and you guys have a great brand a great
community that's highly engaged
so there's probably something to do you
just got to be smart about how to do it
amazing i love it helpful i uh
just trying to uh to share the good word
as always where can we send people to
find you on the internet michael
so you can find me uh twitter or
instagram it's just at underscore
listoria and you can follow and pizza
it's the ampersand is not registered
right so it was a letter at one point uh
but it's a
nd pizza and we're across kind of every
social platform
at underscore listoria and
a-n-d-p-i-d-z-a
amazing man listen thank you so much for
doing this uh you
have taken a whole new approach to pizza
and uh my favorite part is that it's
working
so keep going i'm a big fan and let's do
it again in the future thank you brother
i appreciate it help
thank you for help spreading the word